die Tanne für den Heilig Abend hier
steht sie 30 Millionen Weihnachtsbäume
werden Jahr für Jahr in Deutschland
verkauft das Fest ohne Christbaum ist
für viele
undenkbar so auch für Moderatorin und
Journalistin Sabine Platz ja das bin ich
vor allem aber bin ich ein
leidenschaftlicher gartenmensch meine
Mission heute ich suche nach einem
Weihnachtsbaum den ich mit gutem
Gewissen in mein Wohnzimmer stellen kann
behandelte oder biologisch angebaute
Bäume Sabine findet heraus wie sich
Tradition und gutes Gewissen miteinander
vereinen z.B im Forst bei diesen zwei
waldinfluenzern über eine Weißtanne habe
ich bisher noch nie nachgedacht als
Weihnachtsbaum auf der Suche nach einem
nachhaltigen Weihnachtsbaum mussbine
richtig mit anpacken scheiße ich kann ja
mal rufen Thomas vielle kommen sie dann
komm würden sie sich einen
weihnachsbaum Geschäftsidee mit
unkonventionellen Methoden Pflanze mit
Topf in die Erde habe ich auch noch
nicht
[Musik]
gesetzt ich beginne meine Reise hier in
Schleswig-Holstein 90% unser Tannen
stammen aus Deutschland der Rest wird
aus Dänemark importiert ein Anbaugebiet
ist in lehensaal etwa eine Stunde
nordwestlich von
Hamburg woher kommen eigentlich unsere
Weihnachtsbäume man könnte ja denken aus
dem Wald stimmt aber nicht
ganz und doch treffe ich zuerst mal
einen Förster simon delkeskamp ist erst
25 Jahre alt aber über Weihnachtsbäume
weiß er deutlich mehr als ich
hallo Simon moin
Sabine hallo hallo moin sag man hier ja
toll also bist ja Förster aber ihr
kultiviert auch Weihnachtsbäume ne
richtig hauptsächlich ist meine Arbeit
eigentlich im Wald aber als nebennutzung
bin ich noch zuständig für
Weihnachtsbäume auf etwa 25 Hektar
bewirtschaften und produzieren wir die
nordmantanne als
Weihnachtsbaum insgesamt gibt es in
Deutschland über00
Weihnachtsbaumkulturen eine Fläche so
groß wie Hannover denn wir Deutschen
lieben unsere Tanne 30 Millionen Bäume
werden jede Saison
verkauft 75% davon sind Nordmannen
dichtes Kleid dunkelgrün und kegelförmig
quasi der perfekte Weihnachtsbaum sag
mal Simon der hier ist ja wohl der
perfekte Weihnachtsbaum das würde ich
auch sagen da würde ich sagen das ist
das ein topbaum wenn du nur nordmantan
hast ist das ja eine Monokultur so
richtig toll für die Umwelt ist das
nicht ne das ist grundsätzlich richtig
es ist kein Wald die werden hier
behandelt natürlich wird der Einsatz von
Pestiziden oder Fungiziden auf ein
Minimum runtergefahren aber wenn wir so
einen Baum haben möchten dann muss der
auch behandelt werden vielleicht müssen
wir uns mal überlegen muss der Baum so
aussehen oder kann der drei Spitzen
haben kann der unförmig sein das wäre
besser dann würde ich auch kein kein
Pestizid hier einsetzen pestiz Satz für
einen perfekten Weihnachtsbaum hört sich
nicht unbedingt nach einem guten
Gewissen
an fakt ist im Jahr 2020 untersuchte ein
Labor im Auftrag von Bund Naturschutz
und Ökotest stichprobenartig 23
Weihnachtsbäume auf Giftstoffe 14 dieser
Bäume waren mit unterschiedlichen
Pestiziden Herbiziden und Fungiziden
belastet unter anderem mit dem Wirkstoff
Glyphosat 2015 stufte die internationale
krebsforschungsagentur das ist eine
Unterorganisation der WHO Glyphosat als
wahrscheinlich krebserregend ein und
obenrein trägt der Wirkstoff maßgeblich
zum atensterben in der Landwirtschaft
bei zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch im
Vergleich zum Obstanbau wird auf
weihnachtsbaumplantagen deutlich weniger
gespritzt und je weniger Gift zum
Einsatz kommt desto besser ist es
natürlich diese fläche hier ist auch ein
Lebensraum hier sind dicht beieinander
junge Bäume ich sehe hier Singvogelarten
im Jahr über die ich nicht im Wald sehe
sondern die fühlen sich hier wohl finden
hier viel Nahrung viele Insekten das Reh
liegt hier irgendwo in der nordmanne
drin und ist hier auch geschützt das
bestätigt eine Studie der Universität
osnbrück sie zeigt dass sich seltene
Vogelarten Insekten und Reptilien auch
in konventionellen weihnachtsbaumantagen
wohlfühlen wenn die Tiere aber erstmal
da sind sollte man auf den Einsatz von
Pestiziden
verzichten für mich ganz persönlich ist
ein gespritzter Baum keine
Option Simon aus schleswig- holzstein
schickt mich zu zwei seiner Freunde in
den tiefen Süden nach Bayern Zack und
schon bin ich im Bamberger Forst
gelandet hier gibt's neben nordmantan
nämlich auch eine ganze Reihe andere
Bäume die weihnachtstauglich sind und
das coolste ist man kann sie sich
höchstpönlich Wald selbst
schlagen bloß taugen weißanne Fichte und
Kiefer überhaupt als Weihnachtsbaum und
was ist der Vorteil wenn Sabine die
Tanne direkt aus dem Wald holt ich
treffe Jan Hüsing und Felix saahmann sie
kennen sich aus dem Forst
wissenschaftsstudium und sind obenrein
waldinfluenzer gerade drehen Sie ein
Video für Ihr Projekt Forst erklärt zum
Thema Weihnachtsbäume na passt doch
hallo was filmt ihr gerade wir fil das
große fin
ne vide kurz vor Weihnachten rausk zum
Weihnachtsbaum und wie wir mit
Weihnachtsbäumen umgehen bei uns wie
nachhaltig die sind genau wie werden
weihnachtsbäum angebaut und gibt's nicht
vielleicht eine Alternative aus dem Wald
ja
cool Felix und Jan suchen heute einen
Christbaum für Ihr Büro das wird
natürlich alles für die Community
gefilmt übrigens vor dem Schlagen eines
Baumes muss man immer beim firstster die
Erlaubnis einholen einige Forstbetriebe
schlagen auch selbst und verkaufen die
Bäume dann regional hier oh die sind
alle noch ganz klein ja sind was fürs
nächste Jahr kannst du noch mal
herkommen sagt mal ihr beiden wie alt
ist einer der so groß ist ungefähr was
glaubst du denn rate mal na ich glaube
schon ich also ich schätze mal 6 S weißt
du wie man es rausfinden kann nee sag
mal wie kriegt man es raus jedes Jahr
bildet hat er eine Knospe hier oben und
daraus entsteht der neue Trieb wenn wir
jetzt einfach mal zählen sagen wir 1 2 3
was hast du geschätzt vi s F se Jahre
also plus ein der erstmal auch kein
musste 6 7 Jahre passt wohl 7 Jahre alt
und so klein da kann man sich erstmal
überlegen wie alt die Bäume sind die wir
uns in die Wohnzimmer stellen ja die
sind in der Regel so 8 Jahre und da
kannst du mal sehen das ist jetzt hier
natürlich gewachsen und auf diesen
Plantagen auf diesen Kulturen da ist er
nach 8 Jahren dann so groß dass man sich
den ins Zimmer stellen kann klar der
Wald dünkt sich selbst und das dauert
eben
länger können wir das der hier soll sein
ja ah interessante Wahl der riecht wenn
man die Nadeln bricht so richtig
intensiv nach Orange so richtig richtig
fruchtig orangig findest
du das stimmt also Jan den nehmen wir oh
jetzt hast du mich Felix da hat er recht
oh also über eine Weißtanne habe ich
bisher noch nie nachgedacht als
Weihnachtsbaum aber ich finde die
eigentlich total toll ja ja die hat
sowas filigranes ja viel Platz für
Kugeln viel Platz für Kugeln aber auch
nicht ganz so
spillerig so ready moin zusammen wir
sind hier auf der Mission Weihnachtsbaum
unterwegs noch mal ich lass die beiden
mal
machenamind dieser nachhaltige
Weihnachtsbaum aus dem Wald wird jetzt
Social Media mäßig
geschlagen
achtungung
toll ja
perfekt so ihr zwei ist denn jetzt der
Weihnachtsbaum der selbstgeschlagene aus
dem Wald die Lösung also ein Vorteil ist
auf jeden Fall dass das ganz viel
ökologischer ist ne hier werden keine
Pestizide ausgespritzt hier wird kein
Dünger hingetragen als da muss man
wirklich sagen dass es deutlich
ökologischer und in den nächsten Wald
sind es meist nur ein paar Kilometer
heißt der Baum aus dem Wald der hat ein
viel viel kürzeren Anfahrtsweg im
Gegensatz zu den Baum der beispielsweise
aus schlieswig Holstein oder Dänemark
oder sonst woherkt da ist das natürlich
deutlich
ökologischer und gerade die Reduktion
des CO2 ist wichtig um den Klimawandel
zu bremsen der Wald hat daran einen
riesigen Anteil wenn er denn gesund ist
hier in Bamberg sieht er zumindest
gesund
aus aber die idülle trügt oder wie
geht's denn unserem Wald ja leider
schlecht also der der Wald der leidet
extrem unter dem Klimawandel und der
damit ein hergehenden Trockenheit und
dabei ist der Wald eigentlich so ein
wichtiger Klimaschützer er speichert ja
ganz viel Kohlenstoff ein und das kriegt
er im Moment nicht me hin er ist eben am
Ende seiner Kräfte ja es ist ja nicht
nur so dass der Wald ein
Kohlenstoffspeicher ist sondern er
speichert auch wahnsinnig viel Wasser
richtig genau er speichert Wasser und
filtert Wasser das können wir mal machen
wenn man hier mal so ein kleines Loch
buddelt dann sieht man erstmal was sich
hier unter der ganzen Laubschicht
verbirgt also das ist der Waldboden und
wir sehen hier leider sehr sehr trocken
der ist wahnsinnig trocken der ist super
trocken obwohl super viel geregnet hat
ne also das so ein Stück hat er nur
gebuddelt und da drunter ist alles furz
trocken was passiert eigentlich wenn das
künftig so bleibt oder sogar noch
schlimmer wird was bedeutet das für
unseren Weihnachtsbaum werfen wir einen
Blick in eine mögliche Zukunft bei einer
langanhaltenden Dürre trocknen die
tieferen Schichten im Boden aus das
bedeutet die Wurzeln können die Bäume
nicht mehr ausreichend mit Wasser
versorgen sie leiden unter
Trockenstress dadurch werden die Bäume
anfälliger für Krankheiten und
schärlingsbefall das schwächt die Bäume
noch mehr im schlimmsten Fall sterben
sie ab ein weiteres Problem ein
ausgetrockneter Boden kann bei starkreen
kein Wasser mehr aufnehmen es fließt
oberflächlich ab dadurch kommt es zu
Überschwemmungen was können wir tun um
den Wald zu unterstützen auch Simon in
Schleswig-Holstein beschäftigt sich mit
genau dieser Frage
meine Aufgabe als Förster ist es hier
auch den Wald weiterzuentwickeln neue
Arten einzubringen diesen Wald zu
mischen sowohl von Arten als auch von
alter Simon testet in seinem Wald
unterschiedliche Baumarten das Ziel ein
optimaler Mischwald denn der ist
resistenter als eine Monokultur wir sind
jetzt hier immer noch in einem von
Buchen geprägten Wald ja und hier haben
wir noch nicht wirklich Licht trotzdem
habe ich hier junge Bäume unter die
Buchen gepflanzt das hier ist eine
Hemlocktanne die kommt aus Nordamerika
okay genauso wie der Lebensbaum der
Riesenlebensbaum oder die Küstentanne
die habe ich hier auch in kleinen
Gruppen gepflanzt die
wächst da bin ich auch echt positiv
gestimmt für die Zukunft dass das hier
einige Bäume
schaffen zurück zu den influenzern Jan
und Felix die ungespritzte Weißtanne hat
es in ihr Büro und natürlich auch auf
ihren YouTube-Kanal geschafft em Video
spre sie über CO2 das ist ja ziemlich
viel Aufwand für so ein einzelnen
Weihnachtsbaum und wahrscheinlich auch
ein ganz schöner CO2 Aufwand aber nicht
alle Menschen haben direkt einen Wald
vor der Tür meine Reise geht
weiter vom bayerischen Bamberg auf ins
Sauerland und zwar auf eine
tannenbaumplantage die Bio zertifiziert
anbaut ich will herausfinden was einen
biihnachtsbaum eigentlich ausmacht was
ist im Anbau der Unterschied zu einer
konventionellen Plantage dafür treffe
ich Thomas spiermann und seine Söhne
Lukas und Franz seit 5 Jahren Pflanzen
sie biobäume an und heute darf ich bei
der Ernte helfen hallo Herr spieermann
na ja es geht los bei uns ja total
beschäftigt oder ja das Wetter ist nur
ein bisschen schwierig für uns und da
müssen wir sehen dass wir heute vorank
kommen sagen Sie mal haben sie noch so
ein Höschen für mich no aber in grün wie
ist den das ma ich mich mal frei ja
genau ich zieh die drüber ja hier können
Sie sich frei machen hier in der Gegend
ist sieht keiner oder Nein hoffentlich
passt s meinen sie die ist zu klein oder
[Musik]
nein was sagen denn die Söhne dazu passt
sehr
schön hab Ex
[Musik]
ballfahrersitz auf 10 hekar das ist etwa
eine Fläche von 14 Fußballfeldern
kultivieren die spiegermanns ihre
Weihnachtsbäume Kinder es ist so schön
hier im verschneiten sorpeltal mir wird
ein bisschen weihnachtlich ums
Herz Kri auch so ein dickes Teil du hast
keine schnitchuhe an und keine Hose du
kriegst die Handsäge ja das
gut wie viele haben Sie denn hier auf
der
Fläche 1500 ca die Segen wir heute alle
ab nein nein nein 200 ungefr zi wir
wollen ja für die nächsten Jahre
brauchen wir auch noch
welche die Familie verkauft ihre Bäume
an eigenen Ständen und an ausgewählte
Großhändler Herr spiegermann dieses
Bäumchen hier ist rein ökologisch
gewachsen was heißt denn das ja wir
verwenden keine Herbizide keine
Pestizide wir lassen hier Schafe drin
rumlaufen die das was zwischen den
Bäumen im Sommer wegfressen und somit
kommt kein bisschen Chemie an den Baum
und wir finden das von unserer
Philosophie sehr gut jetzt aber ich habe
das Ding ja nicht umsonst mitgebracht
ne so ist gut ja
Ja sagen Sie mal die Säge haben sie da
seit den 70er nicht mehr benutzt oder
mein Opa wahrscheinlich ist letzte
ernsthaft
na
dann
so der erste war jetzt für Anfänger
danach nehmen wir besser eine Motorsäge
sonst haben die Leute Weihnachten keine
Bäume also er spieg ich habe auch
Gefühle so und wenn Sie jetzt den einen
Baum kaufen auf dem Stand wäre es ratsam
den zu Hause mal eben eine dünne Scheibe
ab abzuschneiden und dann im Wasser zu
stellen dann zieht der Baum noch mal
schön Wasser und umso länger hat der
Kunde was von seinem Weihnachtsbaum
wunderbar einen frischen Weihnachtsbaum
erkennt man übrigens daran dass die
Schnittfläche nicht grau sondern
hellbraun ist und die Nadeln sollten
glänzen und sich noch nicht krümmen man
muss hart sein als Gärtner hartes Herz
und scharfe
Säge
das Sauerland ist das größte
Weihnachtsbaum Anbaugebiet in
Deutschland das liegt zum einen an den
für Nadelbäume guten klimatischen
Bedingungen zum anderen an dem Sturm
kyill 2007 zerstörte der viele Wälder
auf den kaputten Flächen pflanzte man
dann die Weihnachtsbaumkulturen um die
Verluste schnell zu kompensieren die vom
Sturm zerstörten Gebiete waren vor allem
Monokulturen wie muss ein Wald aussehen
um solchen stürmen standzuhalten werfen
wir noch mal einen Blick in die Zukunft
der zeigt uns was wir vorhin schon
gelernt haben aus Monokulturen sollten
in Zukunft Mischwälder werden also Nadel
und Laubbäume denn die Wurzeln der
Laubbäume sind ein guter Wasserspeicher
für den Boden ein genauerer Blick zeigt
dass über die Blätter der Laubbäume
Feuchtigkeit verdunstet das sorgt für
kühle Temperaturen die die Nadelbäume
ganz toll finden Hauptsache kühl und
feucht dann siedeln sie sich im Schatten
der Laubbäume an ein Mischwald ist
Widerstands figer gegen schärtlinge und
hält Trockenheit und Extremwetter besser
stand zurück im Hier und Jetzt auf
Thomas Plantage als Biobauer verwendet
er natürlich keinen synthetischen Dünger
sondern Pellets aus Schweineborsten und
noch einen Superkraftstoff shopsyers
Schafe genauer gesagt das was hinten aus
denen rauskommt
scheiße ich kann ja mal rufen Thomas
vielleicht kommen sie dann
komm komm komm komm komm die haben Angst
vor mir ja die Tiere düngen aber nicht
nur die Plantagen sie fressen auch das
Unkraut rund um die Tannen ab das vor
allem den kleinen Bäumchen Energie fürs
wachsen nimmt nach dem Fällen werden die
Bäume genetzt na das versuche ich
mal Baum vorne reinstecken hinten kommt
raus genau als Alpha ein mit Schwung h
vorhauen dann R der von selber ein und
zeht von selber los
okay Kolle ja klar mal klein
hier sitzt
der ist ja nicht so kompliziert ne das
ist so laut Bundesverband der
Weihnachtsbaum und schnittgrünerzeuger
kostet eine Tanne aktuell 19 bis 21 €
pro Meter erstaunlicherweise sind
biobäume nicht viel teurer eine Liste
der Händler und Produzenten findet man
auf der Seite des Vereins Robin Wood
oder auf der Homepage der Initiative
biobaum aber woran erkennen wir beim
Kauf dass ein biobaum tatsächlich ein
biobaum
ist bei diesen fünf Siegeln hier ist
sichergestellt dass es sich tatsächlich
um einen ökologischen Weihnachtsbaum
handelt alle anders markierten Bäume
sind auch irgendwie groß geworden aber
nicht unter den euweiten Kriterien der
Nachhaltigkeit und noch ein soziales
Label gibt es also FA
Bäume der Großteil der Samen für unsere
Weihnachtsbäume kommt nämlich aus
Georgien dort klettern Männer und Frauen
auf bis zu 40 m hohe Tannen und pflücken
die Zapfen in ihnen stecken die
Samen häufig sind die Arbeiter schlecht
ausgerüstet und es gibt keine
Sicherheitsstandards die Arbeit ist
lebensgefährlich bei Bäumen die das FA
treiegel tragen wird darauf geachtet
dass die Samen unter sichereren
Voraussetzungen geerntet werden und die
pflückenden einen fairen Lohn
[Musik]
bekommen sag mir ihr beiden könnte ich
hier könnte ich hier anfangen ja auf
jeden Fall jaige h sind immer gesucht
Ich will ehrliche Antwort Leute Anfang
für Anfang ist gut Anfang jeden
Fall
nicht schlecht oder
[Gelächter]
top bisher sind nicht einmal 1% aller
hierzulande verkauften Weihnachtsbäume
biozertifiziert und die wenigen die es
gibt sind in der Regel schnell
ausverkauft ich finde die Bäume hier
prima aber was wenn man keinen biobaum
mehr bekommt ich habe da noch eine
Alternative gefunden die auch ein gutes
Gewissen verspricht in Brandenburg gibt
es ein Weihnachts Baum verlei die
Tannenbäume stehen im
Topf aber ganz ehrlich ich bin so ein
bisschen skeptisch ob das funktioniert
immerhin sind doch Tannen pahwurzler das
heißt die Wurzel geht ganz tief in die
Erde gehen die Bäume dann nicht
kaputt tja das ist eine Frage die er
hier beantworten kann Andreas Fredrich
ist gelernter Gärtner und seit 6 Jahren
Weihnachtsbaum
Vermieter
hallo Andreas halli hallo guten Tag h
wie geht's wie steht's gut ja was machst
du ja wir reparieren jetzt hier gerade
noch ein bisschen unsere
tannbaumplantage sag mal Andreas bei dir
kann man Bäume mieten sie zu Weihnachten
hinstellen und dann wieder zurückgen so
sieht das aus zeig mir doch mal deine
plant
[Musik]
so wo wohin rollen wir denn jetzt hier
ja also hier haben wir schon die ersten
Markierung von Bäumen das sind die
lustigen Bäume zweifelslos hier ne also
ohne Spitze das ist so einer für ein
spezialgeschmack ja sie sind sehr
beliebt ach ja aber der hat hier drei
Spitzen oben da kann ich im Grunde drei
Sterne draufzen da kann man die volle
Party machen würde ich mal sagen
ja mein Job heute bei Andreas wir setzen
einige der Bäume in einen größeren Topf
na im Umpflanzen bin ich spitze die
Tannen hier wachsen übrigens von Anfang
an im Topf das machen aber nicht alle
Anbieter von ausleibäumen so die stehen
im Topf sind aber nicht verschult das
heiß sie sind nicht im Topf gezogen sie
sind halt maschinell teilweise
ausgestochen worden wobei die
fallahwurzel zerstört wird der Baum
funktioniert nie wieder der hält di
Wochen und ist da genauso viel wert wie
ein geschnittener mehr
Brennmaterial qualitativ gute Ware
erkennt man also daran dass die Wurzeln
intakt
sind und wir geben eine Garantie mit 6
Monaten halt ne ach so wenn ich den
jetzt mit nach Hause nehme dann gibst du
eine Garantie dass der auch
anwächst unsere kleine Kiefer darf jetzt
zu ihren Freundinnen und Freunden in die
[Musik]
Plantage
also eine Pflanze mit Topf in die Erde
habe ich auch noch nicht gesetzt ja ist
echt ein bisschen merkwürdig ja das ist
jetzt steht der Baum aber optimal es hat
ja auch ein Schutz ehrlich gesagt bin
ich mir nicht so sicher ob sich diese
Kiefer im Topf wirklich wohlfühlt aber
Andreas sagt bei Sturm fällt der Baum
nicht so leicht um und bei Hitze hält
sich die Feuchtigkeit länger sagen wir
mal so für die Kiefer ist heute ein
Glückstag würde ich auch mal sagen ich
finde den Standort sehr schön hier wer
will kann den ausleihbaum nach
Weihnachten wieder zurückbringen für die
Zeit zu Hause hat Sabine noch ein paar
Pflegetipps das Bäumchen sollte man
natürlich nicht sofort im Wohnzimmer
drappieren sondern idealerweise bis kurz
vor dem Heiligen Abend kühl
zwischenlagern z.B im Keller in der
Garage oder auf dem Balkon wenn der Baum
dann in die gute Stube kommt stellen wir
ihn bitte nicht direkt neben die Heizung
so und weil es sicher hier um eine
Topfpflanze handelt muss unser grüner
Freund natürlich regelmäßig gegossen
werden aber Achtung staunesse können
topfbäume gar nicht
leiden was sind denn so deine Kunden
also das ist eine bunte Mischung von
Privatleuten aber wir haben auch viele
öffentliche Einrichtungen teilweise auch
einige Kunden die Bäume stundenweise
mieten nur für ja nur für eine
Weihnachtsfeier für ein Event sogar
heißt die Kiefer könnte im Grunde
genommen fün se mal Weihnachten feiern
in einem Jahr ja die die kriegt viel zu
sehen in ihrem
Leben trotzdem kommt die Kiefer erst bei
der nächsten Fuhre mit jetzt sind
nämlich die Nordmannen
[Musik]
dran komm wenn es kracht noch ein
Meter für eine Firmenveranstaltung
braucht ein Kunde 20
Bäume
ein Weihnachtsbaum zum Ausleihen kostet
zwischen 20 und 100 € Miete je nach
Größe des Baums und Mietdauer dazu
kommen 10 bis 20 € Pfand behält man den
Baum bekommt man das Pfand natürlich
nicht
zurück Vorsicht auf dem Kreuz und gerad
halt ja ich dachte ja du greifst mir zu
ich wollte ja ein pa erstm bisschen
Platz machen einer noch und dann haben
wir einer noch ja der hier ja doch
super aber für schmücken bist du da
nicht mehr zuständig ne schaffen wir
nicht ne
Personalmangel ja ist so mir gefällt die
Idee des baumverleih vor allem finde ich
prima dass ich den Baum eventuell
behalten
könnte Andreas ich habe ein sehr gut
komme ich nehm den hier mit der hier
sagt nimm mich mit nimm mich mit und mit
mit seinen drei Spitzen ist ja einfach
so witzig da kann ich nicht nein sagen
oh we ja sehr schön ein Baum mit
Charakter hast du doch gesagt und
kriegst du auch ein Namen Andreas na
sehr gut ich fühle mich geheht ja
vielleicht bringe ich ihn zurück
vielleicht aber auch nicht das würde
mich freuen wen wenn der ein neues
zuause findet tschüss viel Spaß schöne
Weihnachten wie sich Tanne Andreas wohl
in meinem Wohnzimmer machen wird na ich
bin
gespannt zurück zu Hause wird's jetzt
richtig weihnachtlich aus meinem auslei
wird ein
Christbaum na ja ich gebe zu er ist weit
weg von der perfekten nordmanne die
sonst hier jedes Jahr an dieser Stelle
steht aber hey es geht doch nicht nur
ums
äußerliche und es gibt noch eine
Weihnachtsbaum Alternative fürs gute
Gewissen ein Holzgestell mit Löchern in
die man Zweig gestckt zwischen 99 und
189 € kostet die Konstruktion je nach
Größe und
Ausstattung das Tannengrün muss man
extra kaufen die Anschaffung des
Ständers ist aber natürlich einmalig in
den folgenden Jahren kauft man nur noch
die
Zweige kann man machen man könnte aber
auch ein alten Besenstil
nehmen so und nun stellen wir uns vor es
ist Januar Weihnachten ist rum mein
auslbäumchen ist mir ans Herz gewachsen
und ich pflanze ihn in meinen Garten ein
gebe ihn also nicht
zurück und wie heißt es immer so schön
solange der Sparten in die Erde zu
rammen ist kann man auch Pflanzen na
dann mal los für meinen neuen grünen
Freund Buddel ich das Loch mindestens so
tief wie er im Topf gestanden
hat und und dann immer noch ein paar
Handvoll Kompost bitte dazu so und was
habe ich nun gelernt auf meiner Suche
nach der perfekten Weihnachtstanne
vielleicht dass sie nicht perfekt sein
muss in der Natur gibt es ja auch krumm
und schief und lang und kurz warum
sollte das ausgerechnet beim
Weihnachtsbaum ganz anders
sein
[Musik]